hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast urine toxicology testing
and support of pain management presented
by dr. Jennifer and Colby we're excited
to bring you this educational web
seminar presented by lab ribs the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning I'm Christina
Jolla blab roads now be your moderator
for today's event before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
wandering the question during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located on the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
will answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
please notice that you will also be
viewing this presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located in the lower
right if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know you're having a
problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits now I'd like
to introduce our speaker dr. Jennifer
m.o.b dr. Colby is an assistant
professor in the department of pathology
microbiology and immunology and the
medical director of toxicology and
esoteric chemistry at Vanderbilt
University Medical Center Jennifer
earned her BS and molecular and cellular
biology from Vanderbilt University in
2007 and her PhD in molecular toxicology
from the University of California
Berkeley in 2012 she completed her
postdoctoral training in clinical
chemistry and toxicology at the
University of California San Francisco
in 2015 she is a member of SF s 0 ft ma
TT AACC ACL PS aact and i-80
d NCT her research interests include
developing new applications for mass
spectrometry in toxicology and
laboratory medicine please join me in
welcoming dr. Jennifer Colby Allen
elkridge turn the presentation over to
her dr. Colby good morning everybody um
thanks Kristi for that introduction and
thank you to lab roots for giving me the
opportunity to talk today about a topic
that I find particularly interesting
which is using urine toxicology in
support of pain management I have
nothing to disclose I am of course an
employee of Vanderbilt University
Medical Center in anything I'm about to
say is my personal opinion and not that
of my employer so um I believe we have a
pole coming out perfect I'm I'm
interested to get a sense for where the
audience is what what what brings you to
this webinar why are you interested in
in pain management and toxicology
testing so I mean I could imagine that
physicians would be interested also
laboratory ins because of course we are
responsible for providing and
occasionally interpreting the results
that are used to help pain management
providers determine whether or not a
patient is using their medications
appropriately so we'll just let this
poll sort of hang out and while we talk
about why we should care about pain
management and one of the reasons that
pain management has become such an
important topic is because of chronic
pain so chronic pain is any sort of pain
that extends beyond the expected period
of healing which is around six months so
something that is short acute like say
a oral surgery that results in you know
a week course of painkillers okay so it
looks like everybody here is a
laboratory ins and the majority of us
are doing toxicology testing so that's
interesting that will that will help me
as we go forward so thank you for
participating so chronic pain I'm a
greater than six months so it's
different than just a short week long
course of medication kind of pain is a
huge problem there was a recent study
that estimated about 25 million
Americans suffer from chronic pain and
that's around 1 and 10 on something like
eleven percent of people so this is a
very prevalent concern kind of pain can
take a variety of forms there's
arthritis back pain there's cancer pain
sometimes consider that sort of special
subtype of chronic pain migraines
myalgias so it runs the gamut there's a
lot of different okay there's a lot of
different clinical considerations that
all fall under the umbrella of chronic
pain one of the drugs that we care a lot
about when considering connick painter
opioids and opioids are a large group of
analgesics so they provide pain relief
and there's two main types so opioids is
the larger category you can think of
that as the big umbrella and within that
category there's another group called
opiates and opioids are naturally
occurring compounds so typically that's
codeine and morphine whereas opioids can
be derivatives of those so semi
synthetic drugs like oxycodone or they
could be completely synthetic drugs like
fentanyl and the distinction between
opiates and opioids will become more
important later on when we talk about
how screening tests for these drugs work
but one of the types of treatments used
in chronic pain are opioid analgesics
chronic pain is a big concern here we've
just talked about that and one problem
that's been associated with the increase
in use of opioids for chronic pain it's
just the number of prescriptions that
are given out so this map shows data
from the year 2012 which is the last
year that we have a complete data set
and this map is colored by the opioid
prescriptions per 100 people and the
lighter colored states have lower rates
and the darker colored states have
higher rates and what you will see is
the states that are in the darkest gray
have a rate greater than 100
prescriptions per 100 people so there's
more than one opioid prescription per
person in essentially on the entire
southeast so we have a lot of these
drugs being prescribed and not
surprisingly because opioids are very
addictive drugs as the number of
prescriptions have gone up so have a
number of negative consequences so this
graph is showing data for deaths due to
opioid prescription overdoses starting
from the year 2001 and going through
2014 and the number of deaths and this
is in the entire country have gone up so
opioid abuse or misuse of prescription
opioids has become a major concern and
has led to an effort by all people
involved in either diagnosing or
treating pain conditions led to go to an
effort to curb the over prescription of
opioids so patients that are given
opioids for chronic pain are often seen
by specialized pain management providers
and there are a number of different
clinical practice guidelines that a pain
management doctor might use to help
manage a patient who's being given
opioids chronically a number of
different practice
is have them and there are of course
nonpharmacologic treatments that can be
used with chronic pain and so these
specialized pain management providers
are familiar with these sorts of like
good therapy type sessions or other non
non medication treatments but one of the
unique things about a pain management
practice is that patients are typically
required to sign some sort of pain
contract which is a document that
stipulates how the patient and the
provider will handle a number of aspects
of that patients care and so this can be
things like when and how drugs are
dispensed so you have to pick a lot that
a particular pharmacy patients are
encouraged to send all their medications
to one pharmacy to make it easier to
ensure that they're not getting
prescriptions from multiple drivers how
many drugs are dispensed at a time
transfer of information so if the
patient sees a new doctor for some other
unrelated condition or if another
painful condition should be diagnosed
you know you let you pain management
provider know about that and then
instructions from return to care so
there's a lot of follow-up appointments
involved in this because when you're
giving someone a very addictive drug
long term you want to make sure that
they're using it appropriately and not
developing any sort of aberrant behavior
and so there's often monthly follow-up
appointments even in a pain management
program to make sure that people are
getting their pain treated adequately
and also not developing an addiction so
one of the things that's important as
part of that came contract is confirming
that a patient is compliant with the
drugs that they're being prescribed and
that they're not using any drugs that
the doctor is not aware of and one of
the most common ways to check that is to
ask the patient what are you taking you
know are you taking what I'm prescribing
you and that can work in some
circumstances but it's typically not
adequate for long-term opioid treatment
so there are situations in which people
are not entirely forthcoming about
whether they have or have not been using
our medication as its prescribed and
that doesn't mean that they're
doing anything terrible it might mean
that they're using it more frequently
than they're supposed to because it's
not controlling their pain or something
like that so number those clinical
practice guidelines that I mentioned
earlier recommend that providers who are
treating people with opioids for chronic
pain used some objective measure of
medication compliance and that can be
something like a pill count I've
prescribes you oxycodone you're supposed
to take it three times a day which means
that for a month you meet 90 pills and
in 15 days through the month so i'm
going to count your pills and you should
have 45 something like that interviews
with family so if a patient is not using
them education appropriately then often
a family will have taken note of that
there's also prescription drug
monitoring data so some states have
digital records where anybody who's
prescribed substance like opioids that
has the potential to be misused goes in
a database and the state tracks that and
so if a patient is filling a
prescription given by one doctor at one
pharmacy and then filling something
given by another doctor at a different
pharmacy and that information can all be
reconciled so Tennessee does have one of
those so all pain management providers
will often check that database before
they give a new prescription and then
the final objective evidence such as of
course the reason that we're all here
today is urine drug testing you're in
toxicology so all of this evidence can
be used together it to help a provider
initiate a conversation with a patient
either to say hey think you might not be
doing what you say you're doing or you
know maybe we need to reevaluate what
you're being given so all these evidence
can be used together cohesive picture
how patients doing so since we're here
to talk about your on toxicology we
should talk about how we detect drugs in
here and one of the most challenging
things about drug screening in urine is
that the ability to detect the drug
depends on a lot of different things so
the table when I'm showing you a 19 was
a wee bit cut off there so I apologize
for that
but I'm showing you in this table is the
average or approximate length of time
that you can detect any of these drill
classes in urine and then what you'll
see is some drugs are gone pretty
quickly so let's say you it's a few days
whereas other drugs like long-acting
barbiturates could hang around for a
couple of weeks so it really depends on
the drum and part of the window
detection what influences that is the
cutoff of the test so if you're using a
very sensitive test you might have a
longer window of detection the dose of
the drug the time since the person last
used the drug whether or not the chronic
user or they just use occasionally their
metabolism so I mean some of this is
genetic there are some people who will
metabolize things much quicker there's
some people who are slow so all of that
plays into our ability to detect drugs
in urine and so this is obviously not a
complete list of things that could
impact our ability to detect drug but
it's I think it captures a lot of the
important variables that we think about
when you're interpreting your own drug
tests so one of the things that could be
important and some of the practice
guidelines the laboratory medicine have
recommended that labs offer this but is
validity testing so anybody who is being
monitored full compliance and who is not
compliant and knows that there are
consequences for the lack of compliance
may feel like either getting a sample of
urine from another person who either is
using similar medications or it's not
using any drugs or adulterated an air
sample will allow them to pass the test
or otherwise not get a failure so the
Ligety testing means one thing that labs
can do to try and help ensure that the
samples that are submitted for your in
drug testing are valid urine samples so
there's a number of different tests that
one can do
you can measure the pH of the sample lot
of gloves will measure creatinine so as
you might imagine if you do a sample
down far enough you might get a negative
screening result and even though it
drugs there if it's below that cut off
then you might get a negative so that
would be a way to dilute out a drug that
you're not supposed to be using so
specific gravity will measure a very
someone's they measure the concentration
of a sample and one final way to beat
the test is to add a chemical agents so
oxidizing agents or dish so or anything
that will interfere with the ability of
the screening test to report a result so
there's a couple of different formats
there's no simple dip sticks you test
each sample individually and there's
also automated assays but things like
creating so sort of depends on the lab
and what their procedure is but for
something what you're trying to measure
compliance in a population of people who
might be or are at risk for misusing
drugs validity testing is something that
might be useful so assuming we have a
valid sample what's the first thing we
do when it comes in the lab typically
laughs we'll start drug testing with a
screen and generally um probably the
majority of labs will use a class-based
screen and so this is an immunoassay so
the test is based on an antibody that's
targeted towards a class of drugs and in
this case we expect there to be some
cross reactivity with other drugs in
that class you can imagine they all sort
of bind the same receptor so in some
sense they look alike or they have some
structural similarity and so that
antibody sort of bind to all of them
with some degree of affinity so it's
typically not equal so for example most
opiate immunoassays are targeted against
morphine so they bind morphine with a
defined sensitivity but other drugs like
coding or hydromorphone are picked up
with varying degrees of sensitivity
so class based assays are one common way
to start and the way that these work is
the antibody measures drug and produces
some measurable signal and the result is
positive if the concentration of
detected is above some predefined cut
off and those cut-offs are specific to
the lab or to the indication so for
example the cut-offs use for workplace
drug testing or federally mandated
probation testing something like that
those cut-offs are typically much higher
they're meant to detect high level
chronic drug abuse whereas tests that
you might want to do for a pain
management population that are you're
expecting people to be compliant the
majority of the time and you would
expect lower knots of drug on average
you might have a lower cutoff otherwise
you might be calling people negative on
even though drug is present if it's
below your cut off so the advantages of
these tests is that they're fast you can
do them on automated platforms so
they're relatively cheap it's not as
labor intensive the downside is that
they're not very specific so the
class-based which means that they're
designed and we expect them to find a
number of different drugs problem is
they don't always buy me think they're
binding so a lot of immunoassays will
buy instance things that you don't
expect them to and so you might get a
positive result that doesn't actually
indicate that there's an abuse drug
there might indicate some other
prescribed medication that's it's not
problematic so it's really important
when using a screen like this that we do
confirmatory testing so details about
the opiate and opioid so remembering
back to our two categories opiates are
small category in the big category of
opioids so most will be aiming honest
days are targeted towards mafia
and other drugs will show varying
degrees of cross-reactivity so when I'm
showing you here is the cross-reactivity
table for the assay or opiates that my
laboratory uses this is an avid
architect essay and majority of
automated platforms will have similar
across your activities so the cutoff for
this test is 300 and some work being
across reacts at 300 which is C is a lot
of these other drugs cross-react but
take a much higher concentration in
order to produce a positive result so
what you'll see on what you won't see
rather is any of the truly synthetic
opioids so fentanyl is not on that list
so if a person is being prescribed to
fentanyl we would not expect them to
have a positive opiate result you
require a special fentanyl immunoassay
or another type of screening technique
in order to determine that the person
had actually ingested venue so it's
important to think about the distinction
between opiate and opioid and to
consider that that class based in the
USA is not going to pick up every single
opioid that we might care to see so what
do we do when we get a positive screen
well we confirm that with a more
specific technique and so many
laboratories will use mass spectrometry
for this and mass spectrometry we could
have a whole webinar on how that works
and the use of that in pain management
and in other toxicology applications but
I think the most important thing for
this particular talk is just to know
that it's both more sensitive and more
specific than an immunoassay screen so
oftentimes positive results from
immunoassays will be referred to as
presumptive positive as in the screen
says there's something there but we
don't when we know what it is yet
whereas the result from a mass
spectrometer will tell us the specific
drugs that were present so if we have a
presumptive positive for opiates and the
necklace a confirmatory testing that we
tell us what the particular opiate
so it will say morphine president
hegemon home so confirmatory testing is
specie 82 the drug and the confirmatory
results can be reported either
qualitatively so morphine present or
quantitatively so morphine was present
at 327 nanograms I don't know and the
distinction or the importance of that
number varies so sometimes using ratios
of different metabolites can help you to
determine whether or not a patient took
multiple drugs sometimes those numbers
just add to the confusion because so
many different things impact the
concentration of drug engineering call
that table from a few slides ago so
that's sort of up to the laboratory how
they report those values and I do want
to just say that the mechanism
represented here where you have
immunoassays screen followed by
confirmatory testing is fairly standard
but a lot of laboratories were doing
pain management testing are moving
towards something called a definitive
screen so that means are going to skip
that immunoassay going to go straight to
mass spectrometry the advantage of that
is you only have to do one set of
testing you can measure a whole number
of different drugs because there's a lot
of drugs on our list of things that
might be important for pain management
that are not available with an
immunoassay screen so in that case you
have to test some other way anyway so
definitive screening is is something
that's coming in a lot of the laboratory
guidelines are recommending this as a
good approach for pain management so
what's so tricky about interpretation
okay our second poll so this purpose of
this poll is to get a sense for how many
people typically are doing
interpretations because the rest of the
talk is basically going to be about
interpreting the results and invites so
challenging so given that the majority
of us are laboratory ins and look like
about half of us are people who were
performing drug testing I'm going to
guess that probably half of the people
will have interpreted your in toxicology
results or have some experience doing
that but I'm always curious to know how
how much experience everyone has before
we start this coordinate i'll just give
you a few more seconds dancer
while we there's no results okay so we
have a pretty even split some people the
lab interprets what always interprets
won't allow interprets by results so in
our particular situation the
interpretations are usually done by an
attending so clinical chemist or college
'used but we do them by request we don't
interpret every drug screen that we do
because you do a lot of them so for
interpretations on one of the things
that makes pain management testing and
you're in toxicology so challenging is
that a lot of these opioids are
interconverted by metabolism so what
this figure is showing is a number of
drugs that you might recognize and the
arrows indicate metabolic steps in the
liver that will convert won't drug into
another so the green circles that just
popped up highlighting drugs that are
available by prescription so when you
see morphine and hydromorphone that
could be because morphine was ingested
and was metabolically converted to
hydromorphone or it could be because the
patient ingested morphine and
hydromorphone or it could be because the
patient ingested heroin and
hydromorphone or just heroin is morphine
that was converted to hydrophone so
there's a number of different scenarios
that one might imagine
are all reflected by a single set of
results qualitative results anywhere so
in a conversion here is part of what
makes interpreting was also challenging
so I thought we'd walk through a few of
the different metabolic pathways because
I think there's some interesting points
so study was codeine codeine doesn't
have a whole lot of analgesic effect on
its own but it's converted by a very
polymorphic enzyme called cytochrome to
d6 and sip 26 little convert cooking to
morphine and morphine is very potent
analgesic of course both codeine and
morphine are available on by
prescription now codeine is also
metabolized to hydrocodone which is
another drug that's available by
prescription and so often if somebody
has taken codeine you could see codeine
and morphine or you could see codeine
morphine hydrocodone in the urine and
depending on whether or not your
laboratory tests for Norco date you may
or may not see that so that's another
thing that varies between laboratories
tumble test for all the metabolites some
when we test for certain metabolites so
the test menu is entirely up to the
laboratory so we can get lucky I
mentioned that codeine can produce
morphine you can get morphine just as a
drug by itself so morphine isn't
agonized in a phase two reaction by
Google on all transferase enzymes so
that's what you see on the screen with
you gt2 so morphine is mixed to move on
and metabolites joaquin 3 which is
inactive and walking sticks which is an
active metabolite so some laboratories
will specie 8 north een in morphine blue
rawhide and our confirmatory testing on
some laboratories will not do that so
we'll just cut the google all night
soften know your total morphine so again
it depends on laboratory fall see what
you do but another thing to think about
when you're using an immunoassay screen
is that in urine a lot of these drugs
will have google 09
conjugates or other conjugates as part
of metabolism and so those screens don't
always have defined cross reactivity
with the group run and metabolites or
the cross reactivity with the metallic
might be significantly less than with
the unconjugated drug self so that can
also lead to differences in the ability
was creating to detect a drug and the
other metabolic product of morphine is
hydromorphone as we mention which is an
active metabolite that is typically a
very small fraction of the morphine dose
is converted to Hydra mark lon but
hydromorphone is all possible also
available by prescription so I mentioned
previously that having quantitative
results can sometimes come in handy in
order to determine whether or not
something is present as a metabolite of
someone a drug or whether it's present
because a person took two separate
substances so one thing that community
useful is looking at the ratio of
codeine and morphine so you can get
codeine morphine from several different
scenarios that three common ones are
either taking codeine where it's
converted to morphine using morphine and
we'll talk about where that comes from
in just a second or using heroin so
using the ratio of codeine and morphine
can help you to distinguish between
those three possibilities so if codeine
is used usually the ratio of codeine
morphine is much higher whereas if
morphine substance itself like the drug
more opinion is taken you can sometimes
see a very small amount of coding
present as an impurity in natural pill
in some of these cases we would expect
the ratio of coding to marketing to be
much less than once is to be very small
ratio now heroin contains a subtle
codeine as an impurity and so when that
is subtle codings metabolize you will
often see Cody and present and so in the
case of heroin use you might see
morphine and codeine and the ratio would
be ratio upcoding to marketing with you
somewhere between 1 and 10 less than 1
to 10 so not not a time so ratios can be
useful
going back to oxycodone so oxycodone is
one of the semi synthetic opioids and
it's metabolized oxymorphone again I'm
sure if it's available by prescription
so again the enzymes that are
responsible for these metabolic steps
are polymorphic and so some people will
produce more one metabolite than other
people but both oxycodone and
oxymorphone are active and typically
people who are testing for oxycodone
will use a special immunoassay screen
designed specifically for oxycodone and
oxymorphone because these don't cost you
act very well with traditional opiate
immunoassay in very similar vein
hydrocodone is metabolized hydromorphone
and both of those drugs are available by
prescription so again this is the
situation in which hydrocodone
hydromorphone you can also get
dihydrocodeine which is another drug
bits of ayla by prescription although
it's not used as commonly as hydrocodone
so in a patient who's taking hydrocodone
you could see hydrocodone hydrocodone
hydromorphone I could cut on
hydromorphone and dihydrocodeine and
then depending on whether or not your
laboratory tests for it the other
metabolites of hydrocodone is more
hydrocodone a laboratory doesn't can
find that one but some laboratory of
mine so again there's lots of potential
explanations for a particular pattern of
drugs observed in turn now I mentioned
this for morphine that morphine pills
can contain a small amount of codeine so
we said that those are opiates they are
they come from a natural source and so
as part of the purification process even
though the drug companies selling
morphine might be just you know a very
small percentage of coding present so
these are allowable limits for
impurities in a number of different
drugs and the typically observed amounts
and you can see they're very very small
so if this is the source of a positive
result in your example then you would
expect to see very very low amounts of
whatever the impurity is and very very
high amounts of
ever be active in creating units so if
the patient is prescribed oxycodone and
now on high doses several times a day
and they've been using it chronically
and you might see a very small amount of
hydrocodone present in there in our
example and it could be due to the
pharmaceutical contamination so this is
always nothing that we think about when
we're doing interpretations because as
you might imagine the other reason to
have hydrocodone your earnest because
you can use to hydrocodone so there are
a number of limitations to here in
toxicology testing it is not a source of
truth unless you recognize the downfalls
so a lot of the screening tests are
designed for overdoses movies are those
class-based new meal assays they're not
designed for monitoring compliance and
pain patients so what that means is if
someone is on a low dose of drug or
they're on drug as needed and they
haven't been using it frequently or they
didn't take the dose the day or two
before their drug screen then they might
screen- even though they're not misusing
the drug so false negatives can happen
in a pain management type of situation
because the screening tests cough is not
designed for that indication and that's
one reason that people are moving
towards the definitive screen mass
spectrometry-based screen for pain
management one other limitation is
trying to use a urine drug screening
result to determine whether or not a
person is compliant with their dose and
what the time of the last dose was we
talked about all the factors that
influence whether or not we can detect
driving urine and there are a number of
different strategies that people have
tried to normalize concentration of drug
and urine either to creatinine to
creatinine and a whole bunch of other
physiological parameters body size
mean body mass all that sort of thing
but this is really tricky to do so the
National Academy of clinical
biochemistry it has a draft guideline
right now for monitoring pain management
therapy and they recommend that using
urine results to determine compliance
with the dosing regimen as in how's my
patient actually taking this drug three
times a day like i prescribed him is not
a best practice so sometimes providers
want that information and if they want
that information generally the better
resource for them is to order blood
tests ecology where the Funko kinetics
are much more understood that's enter in
dividual variability and then I think
the last point to make is that we've
just discussed all the different ways
that we can see some open if it's in
urine and the interpretations are not
always straightforward and sometimes as
an interpreter this happens to me a lot
I'm sure for those of you who do
interpretations you're familiar with is
too there are several explanations that
could explain the results and I can't
tell the doctor which one is the most
likely so a lot of the time it still
ends up that the physician has to decide
which interpretation makes the most
sense based on their suspicions or their
interaction with the patient so in spite
of all that we do to try and make this
process easy and to simplify the
interpretations they can still be
confusing and this is sort of fact of
how this works so when we do
interpretations what do we think that I
think about the concentration of the
drug in your brain if you have that
information we know that that depends on
a number of different things but if you
have concentrations you consider about
those ours the concentration really high
is that consistent with
what this patient is saying or is that
consistent with doctors question look at
tabloid ratios and those can be affected
by a number of things so a lot of drugs
will alter the metabolic enzyme activity
and so they will speed them up or
they'll turn them off and that will all
alter the expected ratios in the tablets
that you might see consider the dose of
drug if you know that person's inborn or
their genetic status car they inherently
a poor metabolizer with a certain enzyme
if so then you might expect a different
pattern of metabolites and then if you
know the time of the last dose then you
can think about whether or not that
makes sense with what you're seeing so
the patients that they haven't taken the
drug for a week and you still see it in
their urine does that make sense and
then analytical factors so there's a lot
of things to consider you know the
details of your assay and what you know
about plus closets or false negatives or
interfering substances almost think
about carry over from previous samples
and confirmatory testing in a really
high sample are you sure that the trace
amount in a subsequent sample is
actually present not due to
contamination and then something that
also could be in something to consider
as whether or not you're actually
testing the right sample from the right
person was there a mix-up either
intentional by the patient or something
was substituted or inadvertent either
water samples collected or at the
laboratory where you know labels got
swapped or something so lots of things
to consider that might explain
discrepant result so I thought we expend
the next little while going through some
examples so our first test case we have
a 36 year old woman who's being treated
for chronic lower back pain and she's
prescribed three milligrams of morphine
extended-release three times a day and
15 milligram oxycodone tablets for
breakthrough pain and she's reported to
her doctor that she's taking three or
four of these
today okay so we're going to go through
the results come from the screen I'm
from the confirmatory testing and then a
poll will pop up and so I thought we
would have fun and see whether we agree
on the interpretations so the screening
results from this patient's urine sample
presumptive positive for opiates and
presumptive positive for oxycodone so
the sample was sent to confirmatory
testing and it was confirmed positive
for dihydrocodeine hydrocodone oxycodone
oxymorphone morphine and hydromorphone
so I will tell you right now that we
actually don't report concentrations we
report results qualitatively but
internally in the laboratory we keep the
concentration information so that when
we do interpretations we can go back and
reference it and use it when we need it
but I think the majority of our
clinicians having all the concentration
information would be overwhelming and
wouldn't wouldn't mean a whole lot to
them so just something thing about so
the question that we had about this case
was does the presence of hydrocodone and
down hydra Cody indicate that the
patient took something besides the
morphine and oxycodone that she was
prescribed so giving us a few more
seconds to fill out the poll what's your
interpretation this is consistent could
it possibly be consistent can you think
of explanations and which would be
consistent or can you say definitively
this is not consistent she's definitely
taking something else or do you feel
like there's just not enough information
given to decide based on what I've shown
you
it's just a few more seconds okay see
what everybody said okay so some people
think ur is not enough information you
know it's always nice to have more
information and be curious those of you
who said there's not enough um if if you
if there's a particular piece of
information that you would have wanted
to know I'm curious what it is but
majority of people who responded said
that they think the results might be
consistent and I agree so the way that
we wrote this interpretation was that
morphine can be metabolized
hydromorphone and oxycodone is
metabolized oxymorphone so that explains
the presence of those for hydrocodone
can be present in oxycodone right as a
pharmaceutical contaminant so if you
recall back few slides to that table
hydrocodone can be found in oxycodone so
that could explain the presence of
hydrocodone and hydrocodone is
metabolized I hydromorphone so again
could contribute to the presence of
hydromorphone and hydrocodone is
metabolized that I hydra company so I
think the critical statement here is
that this pattern of drug drug closet
ebony in the urine can be seen with
patients prescribed morphine and
oxycodone so it might be consistent but
we can't rule out additional ingestion
of hydrocodone so often when there's a
this is one of those ones where it would
go back to the doctor right so the
doctor has to decide based on this
information do I think the patient is
using hydrocodone or am I fairly
comfortable that it's it's a function of
metabolism of the two drops and
prescribing so I'm not always quick okay
our second case so this case it's a 62
year old man who has a history of
non-small cell lung cancer and he is
being seen by pain management for cancer
related pain so this is sometimes a
little bit different because drugs
sometimes ago used in cancer pain I'm
not used very frequently and other
indications fentanyl is one of those
that we see very commonly cancer pain
but not so frequently non-cancer pain
but this particular patient has
prescribed oxycodone he's on immediately
release formulation and he's on it as
needed so his screening results opiates
were presumptive positive oxycodone also
presumptive plaza he's confirmed
positive for hydrocodone oxycodone and
oxymorphone and the relative
concentrations are shown and the
question that the pain management
provider has was just the presence of
hydrocodone indicate that he's using
hydrocodone very similar to our previous
case as far as the question but a little
bit different as far as the relative
concentrations so I'm curious what
interpretation everybody would have
gotten this on this particular one so
give you another few seconds to decide
okay okay so not so many people are on
the fence about this one so just our
behalf said consistent with oxycodone
and then results may be consistent the
other the other half okay so what we
said about this particular one is that
pharmaceutical preparations can contain
small amounts of hydrocodone as an
impurity in the oxycodone that the
relative ratio is fairly consistent with
an impurity is the source of hydrocodone
so in this particular case we did come
down on the side of is probably not
using hydrocodones probably just the
oxycodone but again you know this goes
back to that the wider and they they are
the ones who interact with the patient
and make the real determination about
whether or not this is compliant but in
this particular case hydrocodone was so
small such a low concentration relative
to the high concentration of oxycodone
that really felt fairly confident saying
it was probably an impurity okay last
case um so this is a 45 year old man he
has a history of gloom bar back pain due
to a herniated disc and he has a very
remote history of intravenous drug use
and remote being like more than 15 years
in the past but he's prescribed
oxycodone acetaminophen combo tablets so
they contain 10 milligrams of oxycodone
/ tablet three times a day so it'll be
one final poll here but in this case the
screening results again where we hope to
positive for opiates and presumptive
positive for oxycodone and confirmatory
results is confirmed positive for
morphine
from low concentration oxycodone and
oxymorphone so the question was just the
presence of morphine indicate that the
patient used a non prescribed medication
so what do you think consistent with
oxycodone only may be consistent with
oxycodone on me not consistent or we're
on the fence and we want more
information give you that well bit more
time to the side okay results coming up
okay some people think art it is
consistent with oxycodone only about
half vm remaining people consistent with
might be consistent with oxycodone
normally and you know some of you ever
afford of us think it's not consistent
so the interpretation that we wrote in
in this particular case is that the
morphine is is not a metabolite of
oxycodone or is it a contaminant in the
pharmaceutical preparation and so we
recommend that the doctors consider
other sources previous prescriptions I
mean there's a lot of other sources
could be borrowed from a friend or you
know the three-day oxycodones aren't
taking care of the pain and so what's
morphine you know you can think of a
number of different things to explain
this so this in this particular case we
recommend it but they look for another
source of of the morphine so it's a
little less tricky when you're looking
at two drugs than or not metabolically
and or converted or that I'm not
pharmaceutical contaminants hopefully
everybody is in those interpretations
make sense and again a lot of this
depends on what the interpreter thinks
and the clinical contents so goes back
to the doctor so if you're doing
interpretations and you want help where
can you go generally I recommend that
people contact the laboratory to perform
the testing so if a patient was tested
at a hospital across town and they call
me for help it's really hard when we
help them because so much of this
depends on the actual physical testing
that was performed what assays are you
using what are your cut-offs so cross
your activity of that screen etc so
always contact the labs actually did the
testing and then the other thing I
recommend is that people consult the
literature and Wikipedia is a great
resource and I'm not knocking it here
but generally the real published
scientific literature is what I mean
when I say that so I'm showing two
sources that I think are particularly
helpful for laboratories that are doing
clinical toxicology and getting into the
pain management so the College of
American Pathologists one of the
regulatory agencies has a book on
clinical toxicology testing that's got a
lot of good information on
interpretations and common pitfalls that
you might see so that's something to
consider and then there's an article
here by Alex statement and rock
Fitzgerald and they've gone through the
literature and they've put together a
fairly comprehensive list of all the
false positives that you might see for
class base 2 immunoassays and they have
this broken out by the manufacturer of
the acetate and by truck so I think
that's a really good place and I will
frequently look in that in that
particular publication to see whether or
not something has been shown across your
edge because often what you will find is
that the doctor will already confronted
the patient about some discrepant result
and the patient will swear no no I
didn't I didn't take that I took some
other saying and the internet told me
that it cross reacts the Internet is a
wonderful resource but it can make
things more complicated when people
are you know reading interpretations
that don't apply to the test that they
were actually very simple actually
underway so to two sources all the
literature that I've used for the top
today has been cited in the slide but
the full citations are here for your
reference so you want to go download
those papers there they are and I would
like to thank you for hanging out this
morning and I'm happy to take any
questions that you might have thank you
dr. Colby for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A and if
you have a question you'd like to ask
dr. Colby please do so now just click on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button we
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for okay let's get started
dr. Colby our first question is um let's
see how two different techniques are
required for quantitative weasel
reporting by regulation is one single
definitive testing enough so we actually
don't perform definitive testing as a
screen we only do the confirmatory
testing and we perform semi quantitative
results so I mean we have numbers but as
I said we don't you don't give those out
we just use them internally for
interpretations when we need them I'm
trying to think I don't I mean
traditionally as in forensic situations
you want two techniques and I don't know
offhand whether you need only one with
you need two techniques to report a
number I'm not sure that I would have to
check so yeah I would have to check on
that but i think i mean the advantage of
two techniques is that you're quite sure
that the result you're reporting is
accurate so you could do to mass
spectrometry techniques but that seems a
bit like overkill unless the result is
particularly contentious so that would
be that would be my short answer is that
I don't know but it seems that seems
unnecessary it seems like going straight
to the definitive testing would be would
be the ideal approach and that if you
need two techniques then you're going to
have to do mass spectrometry twice then
you might as well go back to your screen
with confirmation because then they
report a number with them or you could
report a number with only 11 mass
spectrometry what are the pitfalls and
point-of-care urinary drug screening for
pain management
um pitfalls of urinary drug screening as
a whole can be you know the
interpretations are challenging and for
results that are confirmed sometimes
there's a number of explanations and
making sure that you give the provider
all the information they need to make a
decision or if a decision can't be made
if there's two equally viable
explanations for how a pattern of
metabolites might have been produced
then I think making sure that you know
you are you give them as much
information as you can but not you can't
move on to cope with the results I think
that's a challenge and then this
question was particularly about the
point of care I think pointed care worse
the drug screening cups where you have
just an immunoassay embedded in the cup
or a test strip I think those can work
really well if you confirm the results
those are subject to the same sorts of
false positives and false negatives as
the class-based grains that are run on
main lab analyzers just a question of
where those are performed so some
clinics find that more convenient
because you have the patient there so
you have an immediate result that
doesn't always tell you upfront whether
or not it's consistent with what they're
being prescribed so again confirmatory
testing is still really important even
if you're doing point of care dr. Colby
can you tell whether someone is taking
their medication as prescribed using a
urine drug test
so taking it as prescribed um I'm
assuming this means you know I'm
prescribing oxycodone three times a day
and is the patient actually taking it
three times a day or you know they're
taking it three times a day they say
they're taking it three times a day but
they you know their clothes got stolen
they ran out of pills you know something
like that happened I mean we can just a
lot and so there's a lot of reasons why
a doctor might be might not be entirely
comfortable with what the patient is
telling them as far as what happened to
their medication or why they're out
early if they're doing am you know there
any more medication than other off the
prescription schedule so in these cases
I think it's really hard to use urine to
determine compliance and you we talked
about all the things that impact
concentration in the urine so I think
it's not very straightforward to do that
so we don't we don't say anything about
whether they're compliant was a dose and
if they ask me which they do often
because they want that information they
want to know they being providers they
want to know explain how hard that is
and why by generally speaking it's not a
good idea to determine dosing compliance
from urine drug screening results we
have
great questions coming in but we're
almost out of time this will have to be
our last question dr. Colby do you
always report the quantitative drug
measurements we don't always report
those we we tend to keep them internally
so we always measure a concentration but
we report to providers is just
qualitative positive or negative we
found that that gives them the majority
of the information that they need and
when they need additional help or
guidance with an interpretation and you
are more than happy to do so we keep it
internal i would like to once again
thank dr. Jennifer Colby for her
presentation dr. Colby do you have any
final comments for our audience I don't
other than to say thank you all for your
attention and for engaging in the polls
and hopefully you learned something or
had fun thank you again dr. Colby before
we go in when I let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through februari 2017
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcer with your colleagues who
may have missed today's by be pinched
that's all for now and we thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye